j'allais devoir appeler le patron d'air
tn o l'année c'est vraiment un pur
hasard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vraiment un pur hasard vous
allez appeler christopher baldelli tout
de suite le patron des retraites je pose
mon iphone puisque je vous rappelle que
vivent les roses déjà le numéro déjà
qu'elle le numéro est calée au régime
moyen terme irez vous le dis tout sinon
il échangera pote arrête le coni permis
d'or tu l'appelles suis dit christopher
je trouve vraiment très très sexy toit
dans la magnifique façonne j'ai envie de
laisser des pecs acerbes au passager
jamais rien et chez moi non c'est sûr
j'y vais très vite cependant tient ce
qu'ils font là il faut laisser un
message ou fait ça sur le répondeur de
[Musique]
christopher c'est là je l'attends pas si
christopher c'est la journée du
compliment et donc tu connais le taulier
il veut que je te fasse en compliments
je suis entièrement d'accord car
franchement je trouve que tu as un corps
superbe
il faut que je te le dise mais je le dis
mais vraiment sans scrupule aucun parce
que c'est vrai elle aurait parait qu'il
faut que je les jetais perte est comme
moi n'a jamais rien lâché dans ma vie je
ne lâcherai pas mais je veux bien les
embrasser alors cyril me dis un truc
dans l'oreille tu sais quoi
hb texte laisse les peg mois seulement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sans déconner c'est pas possible